for academic textbooks I have to make a
slight confession I don't own any of the
books which I'm going to talk about the
reason for this is that my college
library Oxford had all the books in fact
they had several copies of all of these
books so I never had to buy them so if
you're interested in doing a physics
degree which has that kind of advantage
don't you know wanna check out the
physics at Oxford little plug fee okay
so the first textbook which I'm gonna
recommend is Riley Hopson and Benzes
mathematical methods in physics and
engineering this is the maths Bible I
have a copy of this continuously out for
my college life before my entire degree
it's about a thousand pages long it's
it's a big chunky book and it contains
pretty much all the maths you'll need to
know in an undergraduate physics degree
it's like a one-stop shop if you have a
particular problem which you're coming
up with that you just need to remind
yourself of something you need to look
something up then this is what you go to
it's the one maths book which I would
recommend everybody whose thing a
physics degree gets or takes out of the
library there's questions at the end of
every chapter to test yourself and
artists have provided in a separate book
that's all the questions but
odd-numbered questions have answers
provided in the back of the textbook if
you're looking to get ahead for a
physics degree starts this is the book I
recommend you look at particularly if
you look at the chapters up to an
including partial differentiation you'd
be doing very well
next a physics textbook Blundell and
Blundell's concepts in thermal physics
now I was lucky enough to be lectured by
one of the Blundell's and he was
probably the best lecture I've ever had
and the textbook is basically like being
lectured by him in print form it's
incredibly accessible he makes the
concepts very simple the book covers
thermodynamics kinetic theory and
statistical mechanics and at the end of
the textbook there's a couple of
chapters on particular applications of
thermodynamics focus on pool bubbles
thermodynamics of stars and there's a
chapter on climate change all the other
thermodynamics textbooks which I've
looked at have seemed very dry and
boring by comparison it seems to be a
textbook which not many people have
heard about outside of Oxford but I
really think it deserves to become like
kind of the new standard thermodynamics
textbook again comes with questions at
the end of the chapters and I find very
compellingly it also has biographies of
particularly important scientists at the
end of every chapter so you have like a
one-page biography of people like Max
off Einstein
Dirac which I find kind of humanizes the
science anyway maybe that's why the book
seems so accessible because you reminded
that the science was done by people not
just appearing out of nowhere next
something of a wild card
Steve Romans introduction to linear
algebra with applications now this is a
book which I don't think anybody else
but I've talked to on my course had used
and I found it sort of skulking in the
back of my library but I really
struggled with linear algebra in my
first two year course and as soon as I
got this book I completely changed my
opinion of the subject it actually
suddenly became interesting I could
suddenly do it the book really engaged
me with the subject it made me think I
could do it and then as soon as I
thought I could do it suddenly I could
do it the books appropriate for I'd say
a first year linear algebra course
possibly a second year linear algebra
course but no further than that
certainly is the kind of book which if
you're looking to possibly get ahead in
a maths degree this might also be useful
to you you can also pick it up really
cheap on Amazon I looked in it was like
a penny for a textbook plus postage and
packaging no list of textbooks about
physics would be complete without some
reference to mechanics so I'm gonna go
with Maureen's introduction to classical
mechanics I didn't use this textbook all
of that much because again I discovered
it quite late in my first year but it's
a very odd textbook because it can find
classical mechanics with for some reason
loads of limericks apparently written by
some Harvard professor whose two
principal pastimes were writing
textbooks and writing limericks but it
contains classical mechanics including
the grungy of mechanics and I think
actually went much much further than the
scope of my first-year course he'll
probably be useful to you for an entire
degree this is again quite chunky book
and much as I didn't read him most of it
the stuff which I used was very very
useful very very clear and again plenty
of exercises to test yourself with
lastly to round off this list I need to
at least talk about quantum mechanics
now I'm gonna split this recommendation
into two to people who are
mathematically minded and people who are
more physically minded like me if you
are mathematically minded then the book
which is probably gonna become your new
favorite book of all time is Dirac's
principles of quantum mechanics this was
a textbook written by Dirac in the kind
of nascent stages of quantum mechanics
and it's absolutely brilliant it's
written by one of the great masters of
the theory and I think in it's like 200
pages there's not a single diagram I
don't think there's a single analogy
it's
pretty much just mats and if you think
about quantum mechanics in a
mathematical way which is ultimately how
the theory developed it's supremely
useful it's like a tour de force and
even though I'm not mathematically mind
that I still find it absolutely
beautiful to read
if however like me you're more
physically minded than mathematically
minded then I would recommend quantum
physics by Serio X I think that's how
you pronounce that this is a much more
physical account of quantum mechanics it
shows you how to go through particular
problems grounding those problems in a
physical context and there's much less
emphasis on the maths it's kind of more
evenly spaced out in terms of the
formatting which is one thing about
Dirac it's quite dense which I find kind
of intimidating when I'm reading a
textbook so that's it I hope you found
this useful let me know if you did in
the comments or if you have any book
recommendations of your own please feel
free to leave your suggestions in the
comments and if you have any suggestions
videos you'd like to see me do in the
future also leave them in the comments
thanks for watching and I will see you
again soon